لاجئون السوريون في تركيا عادوا مجددا الى
الخيمه بعدما دمر الزلزال منزلهم بقي
الاطفال دون والدهم الذي توفي مع شقيقتهم
تحت الانقاض وهم يعيشون الان في خيمه عمهم
بمدينه اصلاحيه في غاز عنتاب فكرت من
زلزال مثل اي يعني هزي ارضيه عادي وقتلي
نايم الصغير هذا على يمينه والمرحومه على
يساره
شلت الصغير وطلعت فيه لبرا لقيت ولاده
هدول الاثنين قمر ومحمد قدامي بره طلعت
ابوهم الله يرحمه
ورانا فورا هدم البيت ما يعزي هذه العائله
هو نجاه سمر اكبر اخوتها بعدما بقيت تحت
الانقاض ليوم واحد انا كنت نايمه على
الكنباي فلما صار الزلزال وقعت من
الكنبايه على الارض وما الخبر انه البيت
كلياته ضليت سبتي محلة
سمعت ابويا واختك انا عم بصي كان عم بيصيح
لامي وعم بيقول لها
بس انا كنت فكرت انه هو معي بنفس الغرفه
ضليت عم اصيح له مكان يرد علي لان صوته
يعني
بالصالون
فصارى يصيحوا برا اتراك بسوريين قام انا
وهنا رديت عليهم لما اعرف انه انا كنت
موجوده تحت البيت صار يقولوا انه في صوت
تحت البيت لان هون اجوا يعني صاروا حفره
بالحيطان طالع
بس شقيق الاب يؤكد انه لم يستطع انتشار
جثه اخيه في بدايه الامر ورغم طلبه
للمساعده لكن انتشال الجثه تم بعد ثلاثه
ايام
طلعتك من بعيد شفت ايده ايده
غير اصابع وايده يعني
لحتى بينته ببين ظهره وبنته تحت منه نبش
نبش محسن نطلع نصبه نزله على راسه والله
ما فينا
نطلب مساعده ما في حدا اجى ساعدنا ضل
ثلاثه ايام واليوم الرابع لحتى توفي الاب
وابنته وترك بقيه الاطفال ايتاما كحال
الاف الاطفال الذين فقدوا ذويهم رحل عمود
البيت وهو مصطلح يطلقه السوريون على رب
الاسره وما اكثر الاسر التي بقيت دون معيل
زيدان زنجلو العربيه من مدينه اصلاحيه
غازي عنتاب